The Joe Rogan experience.
What were you saying before the podcast
started?
You were gonna bring it up again about
veganism coming from a religion.
Yeah.
Veganism started with the seventh
adventist church,
I believe.
So there was um,
a,
you know,
a group of people that had a church and
the guy that led the church as part of
the church was like,
you know,
they were following the Jewish kosher
laws or whatever at first and it was
like no pigs or whatever else.
Shell fish,
I think pigs are shellfish and then the
guy just said like,
it just sort of took it to a next level
and said like,
no,
no meat,
no animal products at all.
And so these people that were in this
church were like the first real group of
vegans a church.
I've seventh adventist I think is what
it's called is where it came from,
like 18,
63 is when that movement I guess started
everybody.
Sure.
I'd started early.
I'm sure people were doing it earlier
than that obviously,
but I think that that's where the roots
came in and I just find that really
interesting because it does,
you know,
it does seem like a religion,
it seems like,
um,
they,
it seems like a lot of times you get,
um,
I get called out a lot on instagram and
stuff like that from people that are
Vegan saying like,
I can't believe you'd do this and blah
blah,
but I would never go on their page and
say anything to them at all there
proselytizing.
I mean,
that's,
that's a big part of this whole
community is,
it's,
there's the moral high ground they stand
on it and then a lot of these people,
especially people with Vegan in their
name and their screen name,
they always go after people that try to
shame people and what they're doing is
in many ways is a very good thing.
They're not participating factory
farming,
right?
They're not participating in the horrors
that we see these fucking peta videos
where you see cows and pigs and
chickens.
They're just being tortured.
All that.
Fuck.
That is disgusting.
And that should be eliminated and it
shouldn't be a part of modern culture,
but in terms of like the humane raising
and killing of animals,
look,
they're not going to live forever and I
don't care what you say.
I'm not into animal suffering.
I don't think they should suffer,
but if you try to say that people are
not herbivores or that people are
herbivores rather,
and then we're not omnivores,
you're crazy.
It's just not true.
It's not fact and they show pictures.
These are not the teeth of a carnivore.
These were not carnivores.
Stupid.
We're omnivores.
Yeah.
We looked real similar in our teeth to
fucking chimps.
Chimps are omnivores and the human diet
is a very complex thing.
When you attach that human diet to
ideology,
then it gets really,
screw it because you're not dealing.
You're not dealing with people that are
being honest about dietary,
like what is really important and for
dietary requirements,
how your body functions.
What the studies show.
If you look at it objectively,
the objective,
the first thing anybody should say first
thing across the board,
get rid all the fucking sugar.
That's number one.
Get rid of all the refined
carbohydrates,
eat more vegetables.
I think you guys don't eat more
vegetables.
Eat healthy fats.
Get some form omega fatty acids.
Recognize that the omega fatty acids
that you get from flax seed oil or not
as bioavailable is fact from studies not
as bioavailable.
Is it?
Mega fatty acids you get from fish and
meat,
they're just not the meat.
The protein,
you say,
well broadly has 15 groups,
not as bioavailable.
You fucks and you know it's not.
It's just not.
Yeah,
so you can get bioavailable protein from
plants.
You get it from him.
You get it from Keenwah,
you get it from peas.
PEA proteins.
Very good.
But it's not as good as the protein that
you get from meat.
It's just not.
That's a high right,
but no.
You never saw 100 beck from the bottom
right,
like lower back.
We can make that like a lumbar pad.
Work as a lumberjack.
Yeah.
Sleeps all night and he works all day.
Like if,
if you look at Roy Nelson,
he's like the size of a really good
middleweight yeah,
no,
he is.
Yeah.
But meanwhile,
the guy knocked out,
Chuck Congo,
knocked out,
Brendan Schaub,
knocked out some big fucking
heavyweights,
knocked out Mitrione.
I mean fucking isn't announced and
knocked out.
A lot of people actually have.
They'll show.
Did he knock out?
I think I do not remember that fight.
Oh.
Um.
And it was the worst thing is it's with
his right hand.
So you would think that people go to the
hill to left up.
Yeah.
But somehow he connect anyway.
It's like,
you know what's going to happen?
We can stop it now.
Almost knocked out over him.
Remember that?
Yeah.
He heard over him.
Yup.
Stephen's true.
Jesus Christ crazy.
I mean Roy is like six feet tall.
Stephan struve seven feet tall.
Yeah.
I mean fucking animal is an animal.
And I honestly,
I mean look at his gut right there.
How much is that?
It weighs about 2:50,
right?
He's,
he,
I'm not bullshitting.
He is 50 pounds overweight and he's a
world class athlete.
I mean,
you cannot say that Roy Nelson is on a
world class fighter.
You just know a world class fighter and
he's 50 pounds overweight.
So you dropped down 50 pounds,
now you're 200 pounds,
you make 85,
you cut weight,
everybody does that cut 15 pounds or 85
year old world champion.
You know,
there's no butter bean.
we were somewhere,
uh,
and the lead commissioner told me from
all the boxes on the card,
he had actually the best blood pressure
and cholesterol.
He said we weren't a shock that the guy
is in phenomenal shape.
That's what they told us.
Yeah.
That's insane.
Butter being made.
Him Look like Rodriguez.
Look at him.
Jesus Christ.
Actually,
he looks good.
His whole family.
He looks exactly like that.
I hear go upper right hand corner.
Yeah,
that's what he looked like when he was
at its worse.
Meanwhile he's another guy knocked dudes
dead man.
He is so funny at such a good time with
him.
And there was a prince George in
Kennedy.
He was there.
He's a player.
That's hilarious.
Very funny guy.
That's funny.
You know,
he's a fucking hell of a cook apparently
you can't tell,
but it's like there's food watching a
video of butter beans cooking some ribs.
And I was like,
damn,
that looks legit.
Like yes.
Smoker.
Who's cooking them in a smoker?
He broke the rule though.
Don't get high if your own supply.
Jamie was watching the video of soccer
Berg.
How did it go?
He should know the answer is
he dad had to go again today and uh,
I was watching right before you got here
in this,
I don't know where she was from,
but she was saying like,
you're the CEO of this company and you
should know some of these answers.
And she was like,
listing all the shitty.
Didn't know it was like this is
ridiculous.
And then I afterwards,
now they've shown,
which I guess it's part of nonpublic
information,
has notes.
Oh no,
that he had like as references that he
was looking at.
I've only seen one picture of it.
Just very weird stuff that like,
seems blatantly obvious that he should
know or should say that's different from
what we've.
Maybe we think we should.
Yeah,
I think they should be able to.
Fellas,
I get the impression that this company
grew so fast,
they don't even know what the fuck is
going on in now.
Well,
that was the other thing he was talking
about their influence on possible.
Are we going to continue?
Will continue,
don't worry about that.
Um,
he was talking about his influence on
all these different upcoming elections
that were coming up and about how they
wanted to make sure that there was no
bots that were influencing these
elections.
And I stopped and thought about it and
I'm like,
oh my God.
In that moment of him saying that,
I realized like what pressure he must be
under,
what pressure that companies under
there.
They went from being a thing where
people could share pictures like of,
Hey,
this isn't our summer vacation.
And like,
Hey,
you know,
fucking we're going to go to the pub on
Friday.
That's what facebook kind of was,
right?
People would talk about certain things
in the news.
They would have opinions.
You put up something,
a bunch of people comment on it.
That's what it was.
Now with this last election and with him
testifying in front of Congress,
what I'm seeing is facebook being like
one of the most important sources of
influence in the world today,
and it's not really being completely
managed.
Oh,
oh,
awesome.
You're like the Russians,
the Russians.
Yeah.
Maybe there's a little bit like Google
needs to be looked into.
What was going on with my mic?
So Google also probably like they have a
data.
I think someone was just looking into
this,
you know,
people downloaded their facebook profile
and they're like,
my files one gigabyte.
Well,
how much data is in here?
People found out a way to download
theirs and find their information and
what,
what does facebook know about me?
Apparently there's also one that Google
has on everyone and it's much larger to
the busy.
Ah,
Ooh.
I'm not shocked.
I don't know.
There's,
there's.
And here's the thing that it an endless
cycle.
Yeah.
I mean we just don't have that next
unacceptable word,
right.
You know,
like everybody knows.
I think a lot of people know that as far
as somebody who's a doesn't have is
developmentally disabled.
Retarded was kind of the latest term
that was once acceptable.
It's clearly not now.
I mean that is kind of the point,
but before that,
you know,
moron was a medical term wasn't.
Yeah,
mongoloid idiot was what they used to
call 'em down syndrome children.
That was like 100 years ago.
Yeah,
it was on the birth certificate.
Right.
But I'm saying,
you know,
people who are saying,
just to stop saying they're not wrong,
that you know,
but there is also another word down the
pipeline,
right.
There's something else that's coming
that's going to be a medical word or
term and then that'll be used to insult
people,
but that's the way people use language.
Like once we identify this is the word
people use to label someone with a
developmental disability,
people in the slang will grow from that.
People will start using that.
Well,
what's interesting to me is that when
we're talking about words,
you're not going to change the way
people think.
So words are supposed to convey.
Intent is supposed to be sounds that we
all agree mean a certain thing and the
more depth,
the more access towards you have,
the more you can sort of flavor your
conversation.
So I understand what you're saying.
Like if you're saying this guy,
I kinda get it,
but you feel like this fucking guy.
I'm like,
well Tom is really mad.
You know what I mean?
That and to take that out.
Yeah.
It's like I don't know.
So sometimes you take those things out
when you're like on a television show or
something like that,
but all television shows because of that
all censored television shows only
exists within a certain band.
Yes.
A certain frequency.
They never get out of that.
Like the Joey Diaz frequency is like,
ah,
there's no fucking roof.
There's no fence.
True.
This,
this frequency that you get on like late
night talk shows or sitcoms,
this very narrow band that,
that there's no contact in that band.
There's no,
you motherfucker this.
All those things are not in there.
Which is what you're all about.
I feel like whenever you're.
For me,
when I'm watching something like that,
part of my brain's always like,
go find a motherfucker somewhere.
You kind of want it.